hi I'm bovine right I'm the director of
the European police agency and I'm
responding to a question from Alan
martyrs on facebook please tell us what
you care about what future direction you
seek and how many contribute to
improving save the world but my job is
to fight international crime and
terrorism so what I really care about
and keeping people safe and secure from
what is a increasingly complex
sophisticated attack on us by by
organized crime syndicates particularly
online the internet this is a
multi-billion dollar illegal industry
now and organized criminals are finding
ever greater ways more sophisticated
ways to target us steal our identity
steal our money and default governments
and that's having a big effect that time
the financial crisis as well what I
really care about my over protecting the
most vulnerable people in society from
these and other threats elderly people
who are particularly targeted for these
internet scams and children as well of
course there's been an explosion online
am afraid of Charles sex abuse images
and the people behind these are using
the Internet of using the internet to
her betrayal is these terrible
activities I really care about not and I
want to do something about protecting
children elderly people in d society in
general from the threat that we face in
organized crime and terrorism and here
at Davos this week I'm working with
business leaders and political leaders
to bring about a different idea
different mindset in particular to make
the internet a safer place for our
people our children live one new society